welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday the storm is happening on the
one-year anniversary of hurricane Harvey
making landfall along the Texas Gulf
Coast harvey pummeled East Texas four
days inundating Houston and leaving a
hundred and twenty-five billion dollars
in damage making it the costliest storm
in US history
Omar Villafranca returned to Houston to
take a look at what's being done to
prevent future flooding new construction
in a flood plain is causing new concerns
in Houston one year after hurricane
Harvey's floodwaters submerged large
parts of the city 900 new homes are
being built the new subdivision is being
built on an old Golf Course on a 500
year flood plain the grass and the trees
on the golf course soaked up Harvey's
water and kept it from spilling into the
surrounding neighborhood but now that
grass is going to be covered by concrete
and the water will not be able to sink
into the ground and that water has to go
somewhere
Pat Bradley lives across the street from
the new construction what do you worry
about I worry about waking up in the
middle of the night and stepping out of
the bed and into a foot or two of water
Houston mayor Sylvester Turner says
those fears are unwarranted how do they
rebuild an area safely well around is
that you've had storms all over all over
the country you're not Mary all over the
country I understand that but what you
do do because you still want people to
live in your city you want people to
come to your city you want city you want
the city to continue to develop is that
you engage in mitigation efforts that
will mitigate the risk of flooding
architect Brett zoom more designs homes
in flood prone areas and says new houses
should be built higher off the ground
architectural e what does this do it
allows for water to move through without
damaging the structure of the house and
then once the water moves through and
through the underside of the house after
floods it just dries out a year after
Harvey and work crews are still fixing
roads and sidewalks and drainage and
still repairing homes keep in mind this
neighborhood had more than two feet of
water we're talking in some places water
up to my hips
and that causes significant damage the
people who live in this house they're
just moving back into their home but
meanwhile their neighbors over here
their house has been demolished and
those people do not plan on coming back
but this home was built four feet above
the street level and it did not suffer
any significant flood damage houston
city leaders hoped that by requiring
newer homes to be higher off the ground
it'll lead to a lower chance of
residential flooding in the Bayou city
for CBS this morning Saturday Omar
Villafranca Houston I was down there
during the flooding and it's just not
not just a mental health aspect of it
but you have homes that were flooded
that had mold and people are not going
to be able to like tear it all out it's
just just it was just atrocious so I
would really be curious to see how some
of the homes that we visited back then
or doing well or doing now consequences
lingering for a long time